Akkun isn't like that
Always calm from end to end You
can sacrifice yourself for your friends
Be
kind Just be
me  Music]
Tokibichi It's
become like this from time to time Ah, now I'm the Queen's soldier, and they're all at the Queen's command
My cheek I haven't seen you in years It
's too late now  Back Takemichi
Mikey changed after the Adora dog died
Hey
Draken died He was
n't the person who should have
died The tiger dog who shouldn't have died  is dead
I'm here I'm excited about the money I
longed for before I held out while crying Ah-kun The one
you want to help is that
guy
who's dangerous It's
dangerous Mori Royo The
ultimate is love Oh I'll do my
best
Takemichi save everyone and go home
Ah,
it's Abe, the crybaby hero
[Applause]
[Music]